to go to a cocktail party and to see an
hors d'oeuvre that has a toothpick
sticking up from it the point of that
toothpick makes me feel shocks of
electricity down the back of my legs
people are perplexed by that my name is
Carolyn Hart
I have mirror-touch synesthesia
mirror-touch synesthesia is a conflation
of the senses the things that you see
are felt on your skin if I see another
person's injuries well I feel that in my
own body if I see someone get touched I
feel that on my skin I'm a massage
therapist I think when mirror-touch
synesthesia has really helped me when
someone tells me what they're feeling in
their body well I feel it in my body and
I think it makes me more able to help
that person every single day I will see
something that triggers waves of pain it
makes it really hard for me to
participate in a lot of contemporary
entertainment like I really love Game of
Thrones and I can't watch the program
because it's so violent
[Music]
I also have really positive experiences
when I watch ballet I feel my muscles
fire when I see them executing
pirouettes I feel like I'm spinning and
that's not an emotional sense of gee
this is really lovely and so beautiful
to watch I feel it in my body I can't
control it if I was to lose my
synesthesia I would lose part of myself
that would be irretrievable and
irreplaceable
[Music]